on retrouve adrien longeons chercheurs à
l'inalco spécialiste de l'ukraine
bonjour le président et craignent un
volodymyr zelensky en restant à kiev et
en organisant la résistance renforce le
sentiment de fierté nationale
oui absolument venir de lui en fait donc
ancien acteur en fait incarne
parfaitement ce rôle de deux chefs de
guerre il permet justement à la
population de faire corps autour de lui
chose qui n avait déjà mais en fait
observer auparavant dans la mesure où
voldemort de lenski au moment où il
avait été élu en 2019 c'était contre été
critiqué par une partie de la population
écrit neil qui pensaient qu'il ne
pouvait simplement que le jeu des
oligarques aujourd'hui il semble le
montrer le contraire vladimir poutine
lui nie l'existence d'une nation
ukrainienne les faits sont en train de
lui donner tort
absolument mais simplement les faire je
veux dire l'histoire en tout cas vous
avez un certain nombre de chercheurs
l'ukrainien les hôtes et occidentaux qui
de par leur maîtrise à la fois de la
langue du terrain dont démontré plus
d'une fois que les arguments sur
lesquels poutine se fondait pour dire
que la nation ukrainienne elle
n'existait pas et est complètement faux
il s'agit en fait d'une vision
révisionnistes de l'histoire qui a
dépeint en fait de mettre en avant le
destin messianique mais plutôt sinon
impérial néo communistes de la russie
contemporaine le but de vladimir poutine
par ailleurs c'est destituer le
président ukrainien zelensky pour mettre
à la place un régime pro russe si c'est
un échec est ce qu'il va pas organiser
la partition de l'ukraine entre l'est et
l'ouest
oui c'est un risque aujourd'hui on le
voit les les groupes russes ont du mal à
pénétrer dans la capitale de qu'yves
salah qui est très bien défendue par les
soldats ukrainien donc c'est pour ça
qu'en fait aujourd'hui alors que l'armée
russe a déjà envoyé dans la bataille 50
profond de ses ex et est effectif l'état
major en russe aujourd'hui cherchent
plutôt à consolider et conforter ses
crises de territoire annexes plutôt sur
le pourtour orientale de l'ukraine pour
peut-être éventuellement bon l'avenir
nous le dira dans les prochains heures
mais peut-être voilà reconstruire autres
projets nouveaux de nouvelles russie
novo rossia il a encore s'inscrit en
fait dans une colo j ruth qui remonte à
l'époque impériale avec catherine 2 qui
a détruit la crimée à cet effet là est
qu au teen un discours eschatologique
e130 le racisme est aussi orthodoxe avec
cette idée d' à terme la russie pour
répondre au cri constantinople et
devenir cette troisième ronde qu'il
ferait avant postes serait un rempart
face à l'europe catholiques et
protestantes libéral et surtout dans
leur jargon des calanques et vous
revenir sur ce qui se passe sur le
terrain les troupes russes elles sont
supérieures en termes technologiques et
numérique mais ce qu'elles le sont
également sur le plan d'après vous de la
motivation idéologique
alors ça dépend vraiment des effectifs
bien sûr lors que vous prenez certaines
groupe d'ennemis kruse comme les
spetsnaz les troupes de marine là
forcément oui il ya une motivation il ya
je pense aux membres également
idéologique mais lorsqu'on voit les
images des prises par l'armée
ukrainienne qui de prisonniers ruth qui
on a l'impression voilà d'avoir des
personnes plutôt issue bien entendu de
l'armée professionnelle qu'on appelle
les contracts outils mais qui en fait
sont issus de différents
différents qg de la fédération de russie
et qui sont pour la plupart maintenant
prisonniers donc on a l'impression aussi
qu'ils sont perdus et bt donc non je
pense que beaucoup de des russes et qui
sont mobilisés aujourd'hui sur le front
ukrainien ne savent pas du tout ce
qu'ils font et non pas forcément le même
morale que lors de moloch plus
professionnel est-ce que l'appel du 20
10 - poutine à l'armée ukrainienne qui a
pour l'instant eu aucun écho d'après
vous pourquoi il l'a fait
donc je pense qu'en fait il s'agit là en
fait de sueur pour respecter un tant
soit peu les règles qui est de la guerre
en général c'est à dire donner une
chance aux ukrainiens de se rende pour
éviter un bain de sang il ya une volonté
chez vladimir poutine en tout cas
d'apparaître à l'approché du kremlin
comme le libérateur et puis aussi des
ententes de prudence auprès d'eux pour
la pour la communauté internationale
mais tout cela n'est encore en fait
qu'un avec un enjeu
je pense qu'il est il complètement du
temps des soldats ukrainiens à tenir à
ses basques et des jo généraux qui ont
été formés qui ont connu le rss qui ont
été formés ensemble avec les russes si
bien sûr on peut aussi voir face
c'est-à-dire aux tirs et en plus qu'à
jouer sur la fibre en tout cas
patriotique de l'ex urss je voulais
aussi sur saône araki qui l'a mis en
place en disant que l'ukraine et la
russie en fait ne former qu'une seule et
même nation et cela il pourrait
permettre justement à certains éléments
de l'armée kenyane
de déserter mais pour la plupart en tout
cas d'edel ukrainien à l'heure actuelle
n'est pas question de baisser les armes
dernière question il veut le président
ukrainien hélène ce qui s'est dit prêt à
négocier pas en biélorussie mais il se
dit quand même prêt à négocier avec le
président poutine ou sur quoi
pourrait-il y avoir négociations
sur quoi est il prêt à négocier je pense
qu'il est prêt à négocier
c'est très difficile je pense que là
encore il est prêt à négocier en tout
cas déjà fait feu immédiat peut-être une
négociation concernant une éventuelle
neutralisation de l'ukraine ce qu'on
appelle aussi finlandisation
voilà peut-être éventuellement mener ça
paraît cependant difficile avant dans la
mesure où il ya peu de parties enfin des
partis pro russe en ukraine sont
minoritaires peut-être une forme de
gouvernement de coalition entre les
éléments pro d'ukrainiens et
d'événements paru merci beaucoup adrien
longeons pour votre analyse et merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur france 24